picture this if you'll excuse that
foreshadowing pun you're at your local
City Mall in Ohio a place that's never
still every time you go there no matter
what time of day or day of the week it's
always full of people all bustling about
shopping eating dashing past one another
maybe presumably like everyone else you
came in to get some specific item or you
might just be browsing heck you could be
there for a casual date or to grab a
bite to eat at the food court that's
when you remember you need to have your
picture taken it could be that your
passport is about to expire or your
driver's license hasn't been updated
since you
whatever the reason lucky for you
there's a photo booth right here in the
mall take your own photo boasts the sign
on the outside of the cramped cubicle a
list of instructions below describing
just how quick and easy the process is
you take a look at the price list feed
the right amount of money into the slot
and take a seat inside pulling the
curtain closed do you straighten your
back look directly into the lens a short
countdown appears on the screen three
two one a flash bursts from the bulb
above the lens filling the booth and
leaving those white spots floating in
your vision for a few moments you head
back out of the cubicle waiting to pick
up the glossy paper with your photos on
it as it starts rapidly printing them
off you wanted a two by two four total
pictures of your face but then as it
finishes Printing and you inspect the
pictures turning the paper in your hands
you're met with a surprise an unnerving
one to say the least the pictures don't
show your face in fact it barely looks
like a human face at all it has your
clothes and your hair but the whole
image has been warped not just out of
focus but completely disproportional
annoyed that you spend your money only
to receive a highly distorted image you
wander off to find another Booth
throwing the unusable picture in the
nearest trash can now sure you might
write off something like that as just an
odd occurrence a freak of Technology
caused by faulty Machinery in desperate
need of repair but what you don't know
in fact you won't even realize until
it's too late is what really just
happened when you sat down and that
flash went off taking your picture and
printing it off as a warped
unrecognizable mess something was born
located at the end of a series of long
winding concrete stairs and kept out of
sight behind doors marked keep out and
staff only is a lower level of them all
hidden in this dark off-limits area that
no member of the public is permitted to
access there is a service door somewhere
in the southwest corner of the third
sub-basement just taking a look at it
you could easily imagine nothing at all
interesting behind it like a power
generator or a storage room but if you
were to push it open and Venture inside
you'd stumble upon something you would
never have expected in your wildest
dreams or more accurately your most
disturbing nightmares beyond that
service door is a cavern hardly the
first thing you'd assume to be secreted
away underneath a city's shopping mall
although if you're into cave jumping it
would be ill-advised to take a
spelunking Adventure down there the
entire Cavern isn't actually part of our
world it's an extra dimensional space
think of it as its own little pocket
universe that has somehow become
connected to ours and can now be
accessed through this doorway if it
helps you can even picture our universe
as a big soap bubble with a slightly
smaller bubble attached to it in
actuality it's infinitely more
complicated and looks nothing like two
bubbles of different sizes but like we
said if it helps to picture it that way
then go right ahead if you were brave
enough or naive enough to venture deeper
into this cave and not to be put off by
its walls that look like they've been
carved from Pure Limestone then you
would have had to watch your step to
avoid a nasty fall within the large cave
space is a deep dark pit a rocky conduit
in the ground seemingly leading down
into the Earth but taking a closer look
the walls of this pit aren't made of
rock they don't even match the Limestone
that the rest of the cavernous room
looks to be cut from the surface of the
pit is coated in a slimy substance
closer to something biological coming
from a living thing rather than being
carved out of rock depending on your
familiarity with the texture you might
even say this substance is not all that
far off from the appearance and feel of
human fat tissue although you probably
shouldn't reach in to try and touch it
for yourself least about because the
walls of the pit are constantly
secreting a corrosive substance like
acid that could use break down your body
by its molecules painfully burning you
until you melt it down into soup but
there's something else down there lots
of somethings as a matter of fact and
the moment you took that photo sitting
in the safety of the booth in the mall
above a new something found itself Born
Into the pit it looks almost exactly
like you but its face is all wrong you
could even say distorted like a
photograph that didn't quite come out
right the abnormalities in its face
could take the form of lacerations cuts
and open wounds or bloody welts like
looking in a mirror at a twisted injured
version of yourself or this imperfect
copy might have growth spulging out from
its head covering its facial features to
make it virtually unrecognizable as a
clone of you then again maybe it'll just
come out missing everything no eyes
mouth nose just a blank expressionless
mask on a body otherwise identical to
yours and what does the
thing this clone do now that it finds
itself in a pit filled with other
writhing imperfect copies of everyone
that's ever sat to have their picture
taken in that photo booth well what
would you do you would try to get out as
quickly as possible and that's what it
will start doing while you're going
about the rest of your day maybe
stopping off at a few stores in the mall
or complaining to the customer service
staff about that faulty photo booth it's
already started climbing its fingernails
are digging into that fleshy tissue that
coats the walls of the pit as the copy
drags its imperfect body upwards
crawling over the others around it that
are trying to do the exact same there's
no telling just how many of them are
down there how many misshapen heads and
deformed faces your clone has had to
barge past and climb over as they all
pile deep down within their hole in the
ground and what's the worst part of all
this it's not just the climb the fact
that your copy has to fight its way out
of the pit making the near possible
Ascent to make it to the surface no the
worst part is that you have no idea it's
happening you're completely oblivious
that a distorted clone of you is raking
its nails against walls of fat tissue
clambering up from underneath the ground
and even more so you have no idea what
it wants to do when it gets free and
finds you the SCP Foundation has long
since been keeping an eye on the anomaly
that they themselves have designated as
scp-715 given that the photo booth
itself was connected to the extra
dimensional space buried deep below the
mall removing it isn't really an option
sure they could have easily have
cordoned it off and put up signs saying
the booth was out of order to deter
members of the public from trying to use
it but this was the SCP Foundation after
all they needed to run tests figure out
exactly what this anomaly did and how it
ticked Gerald Patton had been a rising
star at the foundation a promising
researcher who had long been proving his
men battle since he first became part of
the organization for a Time the
higher-ups at the foundation had planned
to attach the researcher to the scp-2090
project studying a basketball player who
somehow gained anomalous Powers however
hearing about the photo booth in the
Ohio City Mall he turned down this
request to instead join the team
researching
scp-715 certain high-level staff of the
SCP Foundation noted this to be strange
Patton had never turned down a promotion
before as the scp-2090 project would
have offered him better pay and more
vacation time in order to observe the
photo booth closely without alerting the
public to their presence Foundation
staff on site were disguised to blend in
with civilians and some posed as retail
staff employed at the mall come closing
time once everyone else that worked
there or who had been shopping
throughout the day had finally left the
foundation researchers were free to run
their tests and investigate the
anomalous photo booth it was the night
of a routine Sweep All staff members on
were required to test the surrounding
area for reality warping anomalies The
Sweep was mandatory for the entire team
assigned to scp-715 yet quite unusually
researcher Patton didn't report in for
the procedure the higher-ups at the
foundation decided to let this
indiscretion slide though after all
there were a lot of personnel involved
in the process so patent was let off the
hook in fact the few disparities in
Patton's behavior only became more
apparent when Dr Agatha writes began to
more closely collate and process the
files and information on the Personnel
on site she was the research head on the
scp-715 project and quickly noticed a
few things that didn't add up about
researcher Gerald Patton his rejection
of the offer to join the scp-2090
project and refusal to attend a routine
reality vending anomaly sweep might have
seemed like unrelated incidents at first
but both would have brought the
researcher into contact with technology
that the foundation used specifically to
detect any distortions to reality if he
had taken the promotion or been present
for the sweep he too would have been
within the scope of this specialized
detection equipment yet both times he
managed to avoid being put in such a
position what the hell was Patton hiding
and what would show up if a detector was
pointed at him Dr Wrights was growing
ever more suspicious of researcher
Patton and his behavior however it was
when she learned he had secretly tested
the photo booth himself that she decided
to take matters into her own hands in
order to get to the bottom of what
Gerald was up to she had to mull it over
and think about things cautiously she
couldn't confront him directly at least
not yet even the evidence she already
had that Patton had seemingly twice
avoided situations involving the use of
reality Distortion detection equipment
wasn't enough to prove for certain he
was hiding something both instances
could have been caused by something
completely unrelated Gerald could have
rejected his promotion purely because he
was more interested in that
715 then joining the scp-2090 project
and even Foundation Personnel needed
sick days or skipped work because of a
hangover without telling anyone which
could explain why he was absent during
the sweep of them all but Agatha wasn't
convinced it felt like the two instances
lined up too closely they felt far too
similar to be an utterly random
coincidence even if Gerald wasn't up to
anything dangerous the only way to know
for sure was to observe him but without
drawing attention to it he'd deny
anything act completely differently
maybe even flat out lie if he knew
someone was listening or watching Agatha
was forced to think in a way that was as
calculated as she was certain Gerald had
been his quarters were located in a
secluded part of the sub-basement a
level above where the fleshy pit could
be found almost all the foundation
Personnel assigned to scp-715 slept
somewhere on site their presence their
masked from the ordinary Mall employees
taking care not to be detected they had
installed doors with a key card system
meaning only members of their own staff
could access the living quarters under
the mall if any civilians happen to
stumble upon the foundation and discover
them then all it took was the careful
application of amnestics to ensure that
they wouldn't remember a thing beeping
her key card at the door Agatha slipped
into the living area it mostly consisted
of a narrow Corridor with rows of doors
on either side behind each one was a
cramped room each only big enough for
one person a bunk to sleep in and a sink
with a mirror above it Gerald's room was
the furthest from the entrance right
down at the end of the corridor as far
from everyone else as he could get
although it also meant if he came back
from testing early then he'd be more
likely to catch Agatha leaving his room
and walking back along the row it would
be hard to come up with an excuse as to
what she was doing anywhere near his
quarters especially as her room was
right behind the very first door right
next to the entrance all this was
rushing through Dr Wright's mind as she
used into Patton's room in actual fact
the Interior Space of them was so
limited that they were even smaller than
most ship cabins her hand had been
clasped around the handle of a metal
case which she sat down on Gerald's
empty bed unclasping the clips that held
it closed Agatha opened up the case and
took out what was held inside the inner
layer of protective foam it was the full
moon breaker anomalous Optical
enhancement device a piece of the
specialized apparatus that Foundation
researchers used to record and identify
any person or object that might be
exhibiting anomalous properties it
utilized state-of-the-art Optical
enhancement technology and could be used
to detect whether a subject was causing
any Distortion to the reality around it
by accessing visual spectrums that were
normally imperceivable to the naked
human eye or sometimes even unobservable
in this Dimension Agatha looked around
the tiny cabin given the limited space
she was also short on options as to
where she could hide the device without
it being easily noticed it was also in
imperative that researcher Patton had no
idea he was under observation Dr Wrights
looked over to the sink in the corner
the mirror just above it sure it was a
tactic taken straight out of the big
book of spy novel cliches but it would
work the advanced Spectrum capabilities
of the optical enhancement device would
be able to record patent through the
glass luckily the entire living quarters
had been pretty hastily built which
meant it took little effort for Agatha
to loosen the screws holding the mirror
in place but that's when she heard the
distinctive beep of the door to the
living quarters followed by the gradual
footsteps getting closer and closer it
might not have been Gerald but there was
also an equal chance that it could have
been acting as fast as she could Agatha
placed the optical enhancement device on
the wall and covered it with the mirror
frantically trying to screw it back into
place as quick as she could the echoing
noise of someone approaching sounded as
if they were almost right outside the
cabin door by the time Dr writes had
tightened the screws enough to keep the
mirror in place giving a quick final
scan of the room making sure nothing
looked too conspicuous she grabbed the
empty case and smoothed out the duvet
where it had been laying leaving no
Trace that she had ever been there her
heart already racing it almost exploded
right out of her chest as she slipped
back out of the door to Patton's cabin
only to see him walking down the narrow
Corridor directly towards his room
towards her uh Dr writes Gerald greeted
with a staged smile though the suspicion
on his face was so unmistakable that
probably shown up clearly on camera
something I can help you with Patton
Agatha gave a plight nod back to the
researcher lifting the case behind her
back the one upside of the tight
Corridor was that Patton was so close to
her he couldn't see what she was hiding
the obvious downside being he might be
close enough to clock Dr Wright's
suspicion of him did you need something
patent chuckled sorry it's just what
were you doing in my quarters her heart
was still racing desperately trying to
form a plausible excuse somewhere in her
mind Agatha's freehand reached into her
pocket something brushing against her
fingertips would have to do hey you
dropped this she exclaimed pulling out a
20 Bill and handing it to Gerald a small
price to pay to keep her subterfuge
earlier on in the mall near scp-715 I
saw it fall out of your pocket I had
other matters to attend to down at
anyway I wanted to make sure you got it
back oh thank you Gerald blinked in
Surprise taking the money as she
squeezed past him and walked out of the
living quarters Agatha could barely stop
her hands from shaking although those
Tremors of nerves would have to become
the trembling of absolute horror when
she saw the footage that the optical
enhancement device collected Patton was
one of the creatures from the pit it
didn't seem possible he didn't even have
clearance to know about the pit and any
of the Clones or
scp-715-a's that managed to claw their
way up to the surface were immediately
terminated by on-site security the
instances becoming known as scp-715bs if
they made it that far yet somehow patent
or whatever he really was had made it
through undetected but that was far from
the worst Discovery Dr Wrights would
make she used a number of the same
anomalous Optical enhancement devices to
observe the
scp-715-8 creatures within the pit only
to find that she and the other
researchers had made a grave mistake the
scp-715-as they were all humans but the
foundation had initially thought were
the distorted imperfect clone copies of
everyone who had used the scp-715 photo
booth were actually The Originals they
had been trying to climb back up because
they wanted to come home their places
taken by
scp-715-bs but none of those people now
Twisted disfigured and unrecognizable
were able to explain to the foundation
who they were and they'd been shot left
to fall back into the pit and die acting
fast Dr Wright's updated the
classification of scp-715 to ketter
although This was later rescinded back
to Safe the creature that looked like
researcher patent was apprehended and
brought in for interrogation after
learning the truth behind scp-715 the
photo booth was secured and locked up
permanently but as of now the project
investigating scp-715 has been put on
hold no one at the foundation wants to
admit their mistake that they now have
an extra dimensional pit full of
innocent distorted people or that they
have no idea where all their body
swapped counterparts are now go and
check out scp-1733 season opener for
another tale of another anomaly caught
on film this time it's a basketball game
that you won't be able to stop watching
or if you'd rather further your
investigation into some more paranormal
photography then we've got just the
video for you
scp-978 the desire camera